okay oh God it's 1:40 in the afternoon
and I'm having a cup of half caffeinated
half acidic coffee and I haven't had any
coffee in weeks and I don't have any
good sense of time so it could have been
months this might be a terrible decision
I've been drinking tea for so long and
it's been so nice it's calm my anxiety
it's calm my stomach but there's
something about coffee it's dangerous
that gives you dangerous shs I've been
listening to my inner child enough it's
time to listen to my inner sabur again
that's good I think is that good is it
good it's fine this will be for special
occasions I'm a fragile little Fab egg
of a human now I have to treat myself
with delicate and gentle hands we'll
have our half caffeinated coffee for
special occasions every day can be
special if you're an optimist I'm alive
that's how I should have started all of
these videos in this cancer series or
whatever this is I don't know if it's a
series or if it's the start of some
something new that sounds like a lyric
in a Taylor Swift song I have my
lumpectomy last week and I'm on the mend
I'm doing really well just this area is
sore my armpit is sore and my left
breast is sore and swollen it's Tuesday
December 26th the day after Christmas I
got my lumpectomy exactly one week ago
and I will find out the results from the
lumpectomy on Thursday so I'm just
existing in this very strange pocket of
time so I thought I would shoot a video
to help me pass the time and because I
wanted to I did some half ass vlogging
leading up to surgery I think I didn't
fully commit to the idea of vlogging
because I don't know maybe I was just
like nervous and there wasn't a lot
going on so let's look at some random
stuff I filmed before surgery sorry I'm
out of breath for a really good reason I
just walked on my treadmill for 25
minutes very slow speed that's like the
first voluntary form of exercise that
I've done
since May I think other than taking my
dog out oh my God I'm so excited is this
what endorphin rush feels like after
your first very minimal workout that was
basically kin to mall
walking oh my goodness
thrilling oh my God there's a coyote out
there do you see this what the
hell there's a
coyote running down hey whoa that was
crazy
oh my God say my heart's beating fast
but it it was before
whoa oh my you know
the okay the last time that happened
literally Elliot was sitting on right
here and I was telling him I found out
that I had breast cancer before we went
to the doctor to find out because my
labs were posted on my profile for the
hospital's website and literally as I
was telling him a coyote that ex did the
exact same thing that that one just did
I know this doesn't seem that crazy but
Ellie and I um just to catch you up both
went to graduate school for depth
psychology learned a lot about symbolism
metaphor of the psyche and that right
there is huge for us and the education
that we've spent two years during the
pandemic in and that he's still
currently in getting his PhD whoa okay
wow so crazy morning I'm going to
hydrate and text Elliot who's out at
therapy right now that that happen so
that's the update oh she turned the
camera on for this good morning it's
Monday morning and what's the most fun
thing to do on a Monday morning go get a
chest x-ray I mean have you tried it
morning I'm getting a chest x-ray just
so they can make sure that my lungs and
everything are good for surgery it's
9:30 in the morning now we have all all
the car Necessities to travel we have
tea water with liquid IV in it car
crackers and tissues those are the
essentials these days I haven't even
looked at what a chest x-ray actually is
I'm assuming it's a quick non-invasive
thing but with my luck who knows they're
going to be like we actually have to
biopsy both of your breasts and your
feet today we'll see that was so quick
and painless and all I had to do is take
my bra I didn't even have to put those
on I'm already back in my car that was
so quick and painless I can't believe it
the kindest x-ray technician I am not
sure what they're called item
see-through specialist named cherl this
absolutely lovely woman named Cheryl
just told me to take my bra off she took
a couple pictures of me and I was on my
way you hear about that kind of stuff
happening in Los Angeles but never does
she leave this pleas and I got to keep
my shirt on there's very rarely a
doctor's appointment in this scenario in
which I get to keep my shirt on these
days so that was a great time wow what
about this one over the weekend I got a
hankering for tiasu and then I realized
I've never made tiasu before so I went
out to the grocery store and bought the
ingredients to make tiasu I'm going to
try to make tiasu it's got a cool in a
refrigerator for hours so it makes sense
to do it now it'll be ready later when
we're high and hungry my grocery store
did not have lady fingers so instead I
got nilow Wafers which are supposed to
be an okay substitute we'll see let's
let's find
[Music]
out wow now this goes in the fridge for
like 3 hours that was really easy ooh
Look at Her filming this part so it is
Monday December 18th I haven't vlogged
in so long I shot the Q&A video uh
haven't vlogged I don't know I was
thinking because I was just like in a
momentum of not vlogging that I would
just continue not to but I'm going to
record and we'll see I had therapy this
morning because tomorrow is my surgery
tomorrow is my lumpectomy and I'm just
like making sense of how I I'm nervous
I'm nervous about it any surgery is
nerve-wracking I've never had an a
surgery this intense but it should be
fine they do these all the time I'm
going in today for something crazy
what's a a crazy named thing
lymphoscintigraphy scintigraphy skin
graphy skin skin graphy Shenanigans
going on so they're doing that for my
lymph nodes I believe because my lymph
nodes will be biopsied tomorrow I
believe they're going in there they're
getting some stuff they're getting out
of there they're pillaging this area of
my body basically tomorrow I believe
today they're taking some images we're
going to find out when we get there my
process in this process which might be
very different than others in this
process and in fact I know for sure is
process is that I don't like to
overwhelm myself with the details some
might call that living in Blissful
ignorance it has been a pretty okay
system so far pretty okay not Flawless
mm- it's not a Flawless system it could
use some improvements I could probably
ask more questions get more information
but who's got the time oh just me I have
nothing but time I was trying to talk in
therapy this morning about how I'm
feeling and I feel very like numb is in
a way but I think that's just I'm a
little overwhelmed and scared and
nervous and so my body just sort of
shuts into a numb and we'll just like
play Scrabble on my phone for like an
hour straight and that's how I realized
like oh I I think I'm a little scared
anyway we made some tea we're going to
leave in about an hour would you like to
come along is I don't know how much I'll
record there to pull out a whole camera
in a medical facility when stuff's going
on is a big to-do and I just don't have
the personality for
[Music]
that ooh got to get this next part on
camera am I bullying myself and then
surgery day happened and I did some very
minor vlogging on surgery day I think
I'm not totally sure here's whatever I
put together this is a nice little scene
for potentially horrific day just
kidding just kidding it's a great day I
didn't sleep well it's surgery day we're
getting ready to go over to surgery
and God I'm slow today I'm not allowed
to eat or drink anything so I don't know
what to do with myself because my
mornings have gotten into a routine of
making myself a delicious matcha so now
I can't do any of that so I'm just
standing in the kitchen when I'm
stressed I want to eat little treats and
I can't do that this morning so we're
just standing around unsure of how to be
and what to
do but let's go get surgery today
another step in the process that seems
never
ending on our way to surgery my head's
cold but also Elliot and I are wearing
basically the same exact outfit oh no
this gives off Eerie Vibes I feel like
for the surgeons we do everything
[Music]
together twins twins on the Move twins
on the
[Music]
[Applause]
Move I've already done one procedure
they took me downstairs and they put two
wires in my
boat I haven't looked at it that was
insane it's happening so another thing I
like to do I like to make sure that my
patients have gotten okay just got back
from surgery Elliot went to the store to
get himself a beer because that boy has
earned it today I have an ice pack going
on it was a success I feel very groggy
everyone was so nice we'll see how the
recovery goes the next couple days I
can't believe they put two wires I knew
they were doing guide wire stuff and and
I guess I didn't realize how literal
that description of the procedure would
be me and that mamogram machine have a
very tumultuous relationship they put me
in the mamogram machine like my mamogram
biopsy and instead of doing the biopsy
needle they put two little wires in my
boob and then taped it up I went back
upstairs to get ready for surgery so I
just sat there like this trying
desperately not to look at the chaos
going on down there man getting knocked
out for surgery is just so awesome I
love it but I don't know if I said
anything weird cuz Elliott wasn't back
there with me I just have to live with
the uncertainty a totally different kind
of uncertainty not MediCal uncertainty
just like social embarrassment
uncertainty of if I said anything
strange in the fog before I totally came
to around some of the nicest nurses
we're not going to dwell in that we have
other things to worry about and also
much to celebrate did it oh my God
that's so cool hell yeah surgery's
done that's so cool and that leads us up
to here now one week after surgery IID
mentioned in my last Q&A video should I
do a part two and a lot of you said yeah
do part two and that's all I needed was
literally one person going yeah do part
two the blood of Christ how's it been
dealing with all the embarrassing
physical stuff that comes with chemo it
is wild that everyone's cancer
experienced though very similar is very
much unique at the same time our bodies
all respond to similar treatments in
different ways I got sent home with all
these pamphlets of information about the
medications I had and would be taking
during chemo days and what the full list
of side effects would be get presented
with these just terrible things in a
list and you're going uhoh what Bingo
number is going to be called for me
which one of these am I going to
experience so you basically prepare for
a war with yourself I'm talking a lot in
therapy now about I've had a lot of I
guess more emotional days because I'm
kind of unpacking how crazy the last few
months were for me though I was like
trying to process in real time you're
just handling so much so quickly just
the entirety of your treatment and the
journey that you go on you're kind of
just pushed into immediately and you
quickly have to start so there's not a
lot of time anywhere other than at the
very end to really think about what you
just did and what your body just did the
diarrhea stuff started happening Fast
and Furious I mean I was like Vin Diesel
in here it was Too Fast Too Furious you
just sort of have to deal with it I'm
thankful to have a husband that like you
know if I was nervous about farting in
front of him before like all bets are
off at this point I was stinking up the
joint every day he's respectful enough
to not tell me constantly what he could
overhear but Lord knows that boy heard
some Horrors happening in these
bathrooms in this house and he's been
nothing but loving about it so having a
support system that can either help you
laugh or love you unconditionally
through these conditions is really
helpful help them to feel human when
they really probably feel so alien
because of what their body is
experiencing even more reason to support
those that are going through this I
can't even say the word sh without just
just like immediately flashing back to
the emergency room bathroom floor on my
hands and
knees what are your feelings thoughts as
we approach the New Year oh man' I am
starting to generate some feelings and
thoughts because there's been so many
other things for me to think about up
until now and now I'm like wow it's the
end of the year wild cosmically that
this is all lined up as we start 2024
that I really do feel like I'm having
this like rebirth thing going on that
I'm in the middle of right now I do feel
incredibly disoriented a lot of the time
but I'm trying to reorient myself as my
world now opens up a little bit after
chemo around who I am as a person what I
care about and what I would like to do
I'm working with fear a lot as an
emotion that is incredibly powerful in
my world and has the ability to show me
areas of my life that I want to explore
but also has the ability to hinder me
from doing any exploration trying to get
back to following my fears rather than
letting them sit on me like a weighted
blanket I love Fresh Starts I love fresh
starts when I was younger I love
rearranging my room and being like I'm a
brand new [__] now look at me
everything's going to work out great
because my bed's over there and my walls
are lime green now one of my plans
before we start the new year is to
really sit down and think of goals
obviously like a lack of Direction comes
from a lack of goals and I'd like to
have some momentum and direction in 2024
gentle though gentle I don't want to be
strict and restrictive [__] to myself I
want these to be goals with the open
endedness of adapting to whatever might
come I really do feel like one of these
guys 2023 was a weird year weird year
2024 I'd like for it to be a better year
did you find it hard to tell people you
have cancer this is a great question
telling people that I had breast cancer
was so hard I hate worrying anyone I
hate bothering anyone I didn't tell
anyone other than my little brother that
I was having a biopsy originally so
unfortunately because no one knew that I
was even dealing with the lump it came
out of left field to tell my parents
that I had breast cancer and that was
that was really hard to do and they all
took it so well I mean it was incredibly
shocking across the for to tell friends
I kind of the way I did it because I'm
scared of telling people something so
serious I just want to be able to tell
people difficult things while having the
conclusion on how it won't be difficult
anymore there was no way to do that I
drafted up texts to them and I ran them
by Elliott and then I sent one kind of
like a day to each friend because that's
emotionally how much I could handle and
I wanted to give space to be able to
respond but that's also just my own
people pleasing tendencies that I bumped
up against that were you know out the
window at that point so if someone does
tell you that they have cancer I think
the best reaction if you can in that
shocking situation is a calm and
supportive response my mom actually was
just immediately like okay you can do
this you're going to get through this
just so definitively wasn't emotional I
mean she probably cried after we got off
the phone but she was so steady so
immediately and it was really helpful
but on the flip side of it being very
difficult once I told people I did feel
this like beautiful sense of deeper
connection and vulnerability the first
kind of real emotional boost of like you
did something really hard you can do
this you didn't
die I'm not even going to make I'm not
even going to make a joke there was just
the lingering thing of than telling the
internet and that was also very
difficult but after telling people and
feeling like I did that like I did it
that was a huge boost of encouragement
that I could do hard things have you
ever witnessed a UFO let's just move on
to that I have not witnessed a UFO UAP I
believe we're supposed to use UAP
unidentified aerial phenomenon my
husband is pretty into the world of uaps
in fact he wrote an academic paper on it
that is getting published so I don't
mean to toot his horn but Hong hongk
ouch I have not but would I like to I
think I would like to but I'm uncertain
on that I need some time away from this
scenario to resettle myself and then the
uaps you are allowed to present yourself
to me because I will be emotionally well
again do you feel like you grew up on
the Internet what are your feelings on
that no I don't Jen Z you guys grew up
on the Internet Millennials uh no which
I think is why we have a different type
of anxiety than you have Millennials
grew up being introduced to the internet
in some of their formative years when I
was a teenager that's when you know AOL
insta messenger and the ability to
connect from home started but I also
remember my childhood without any
screens so Millennials have this weird
tension of knowing a life without it and
then adapting to a life with it gen Z
knows this tension of just having access
to too much information as soon as they
were introduced to the world I get all
the anxiety and overwhelm I understand
it it's too much power too much
information too much access I think no
wonder we're all obsessed with talking
about boundaries oh I'm also realizing
that you mean grow up on the Internet
like I put my whole life out there on
the internet no I don't feel that way
you've seen some of my life but
definitely not all of it and a lot of my
major struggles in life during college
happened before I put anything on the
internet that's where I kind of
discovered my ability to put things on
the internet and thankfully um that
happened post an era where I was
struggling a lot I don't think I grew up
on the internet I think I'm I put things
on the internet as I grow does that make
sense okay we're rambling how does it
feel to look back on your earlier
content IE daily grace or early it's
Grace for years I've had this very
immediate immediate cringe at the
thought of looking at Old content I had
this phase where I would get really
drunk and watch old content that I
thought was good and think wow I'll
never do something like that again I
think happened because I was very
depressed and lost and struggling and
then I have this phase where I just feel
very kind of cringey at looking back at
Old content and I'm trying to understand
where the cringe comes from I think it
comes from knowing that there was a lot
of different struggle happening behind
the scenes in a lot of those years while
trying to put on a fun face for a camera
online I think I'm morphing that cringe
phase into a phase where I have more
compassion for the girl making that
content and respect for the girl making
that content because she was doing her
best and I have a lot more tools now at
understanding my mental health that I
didn't have back then does that mean I'm
going to look back at my old content
right now
no but the thought of possibly doing it
at some point doesn't totally gross me
out that's progress that's
progress she's still the same girl are
you planning on writing a new book yes
and lot of what I'm talking about here
in vages if that's a word I should start
to learn which words are words and which
ones aren't cuz I'm going to write a new
book I have started writing a new book
before I got diagnosed and then I got
diagnosed and my brain has just been
through a lot I think there's a brand
new chapter that has been writing itself
over the last 6 months there's a lot
more to say in this book I think than um
I have I really want to reflect on kind
of the psychological Journey as someone
that found the themselves online the way
that I did a lot of it is about the
duality of like wanting to put myself
out there while struggling internally
with a lot of emotional and
psychological stuff that I'm learning a
lot about over the last few years if
that makes sense what things did doctors
do that made you feel most cared for
brand new dock here congratulations on
being a doctor that's not an easy thing
to do if there's one thing I have
absolutely learned through this process
is that I have no interest in working in
the medical field at all whatsoever nor
was I ever designed as a human being to
be in that field I don't understand
anything going on there and I have
nothing but respect for those that work
there and do know what's going on but
the thing that doctors did that make me
feel most cared for detailed responses
to questions before this surgery I had
emailed my surgical doctor with a bunch
of follow-up questions that I had that I
didn't think of in the moment that we
were talking about it originally and she
responded to my email with just like
full answers to each question fully
typed out within like 2 hours of sending
the email and that was just amazing for
me as a visual person that is very
forgetful to have an email with all of
these answers in was incredible any sort
of like Clarity of explanation and
openness to question answering was
incredible especially as someone that's
still learning to advocate for myself in
this world and gets afraid to ask dumb
questions sometimes to be able to have
have just such um thoughtful responses
was super helpful oh and for those of
you that are going through this process
here's a little tip that actually really
helped us out a lot when we would have
doctor's appointments Elliot will record
the session with the doctors you can ask
your doctor if it's okay to record and
then transcribed it um when we got back
so that I could see all of the things
that we talked about like written out
auditorily for me I don't retain things
a lot and often I get distracted by
people's faces and the way they move
when they talk to me so when when I'm
looking in the doctor in the eye I'm not
really listening to what he's saying I'm
looking at like does he trim his
eyebrows and that's on me you know it's
on me best advice for someone starting
chemo next month for breast cancer you
can do it you can do hard things you can
do things that you don't think you can
do remind yourself that it is temporary
this is temporary it will not last
forever write that on a mirror write it
on a piece of paper paint it all over
your walls tell your significant other
or your family member to remind you and
text you that this is not going to last
forever the times that I would spiral
were the times that I felt just so
completely suffocated by the experience
and that I was never going to get out of
it when I was reminded that it was
temporary it was so much easier to
handle but you can do it you can do hard
things and it is temporary okay that
this camera is going to die soon so I
think that is it for answering your
questions thank you again for all these
great questions and I will keep you
posted on this series of events as they
continue I don't think I'll be posting a
video before next year so happy 20 24
let's do it let's start facing and
following our fears and not letting them
F us over other than that I don't know
and that's okay